[Musique]
or c'est important pour vous des copains
oui c'est très important et ça occupe
une grande place chez moi oui oui me
sens que je me sentirai seul si j'en
avais pas il me semble que c'est même
nécessaire oui les revoir pour moi de
les revoir une fois par semaine pour
certains plus on a besoin de les
retrouver de discuter quoi de cyber et
de septembre est du sérieux de la
semaine on a besoin de deux vidéos et de
terreur j'ai pas moins d'erreurs dire
quoi justement je sais pas moi de dire
merde contre une envie de le dire quand
on entend copains quoi et dites-moi
fortune motifs lots je suis employé des
sciences
c'est plus les choisit ce métier oui je
les choisis de oui mon plein gré oui oui
ça vous plaît oui ça me fait pas que ça
me plaise m'enfin ça me convient c'est
ce que dans ce que j'avais pensé faire
pourquoi vous dites que ça vaut combien
pourquoi parce que je pensais travaillé
chez m mais dans les bureaux quoi
c'était mon idée offert et le bureau à
l'usiné
oui bonsoir c'est moins abruti sens et
c'est moi ça ou seppi je pensais ce
petit je prends pour moi c'est mieux
quand j'ai mis en jeu ni au singe et
mieux les bureaux au fond est ce que
votre travail
l'idée votre travail occupe une grande
place dans vos pensées
c'est à dire en ce moment ils en
occupent heures oui beaucoup et parce
que j'ai eu du mal un peu à me réadapter
toussaint de la government et pourquoi
pas ce que je remets d'algérie quoi
j'étais récemment libérés ah parce que
rené du service militaire
je suis revenue l'armée a récemment là
alors je sais ce que je m'étais dit
alarmé pendu penser je disais je vais
rentrer je vais travailler je vais je
faire un top truck quoi puis en entrant
savoir on retrouve les amis 12 ans on
pense moins à travailler on pense déjà
plus à s'amuser on a besoin quoi de une
fois qu'on est infini l'armée on a
besoin d'eux de se libérer un bon coup
pour de bon co2 de jeu prend de vous
libérer de quoi parce que enfin l'armée
quoi vous ignorez pas qu'on ait tenu
coup un peu alors on a besoin de chez
promodès de sortir tous les taux varient
oui d'être libre sur tout et pour tout
le temps voir quelqu'un de ré à vous qui
vous lisent à telle info est rentré on a
besoin de bouger quoi enfin deux autres
mendient vous donner une grande place
aux amusements
oui j'en donne en ce moment oui je donne
une grande place à vous amuser membres
et est alors qu'ils sont ils sèment une
ces amusements défis dont deux de sortir
du champ beaucoup que j'aime sortir quoi
entre copains avec des copains avec des
filles quand ça se présente oui j'ai
sorti beaucoup avec les filles oui
j'essaye le plus souvent sorti avec les
filles oui parce que j'aime j'aime mieux
être en compagnie de fiqh avec je sais
pas je déteste sortir avec mes copains
quoi mais je me sentirai des filles pour
et puisque ça se comprend pas les
moindres sorties avec des filles raconté
- différemment ça se passe où j'ai
rencontré ou d'abord les filles avec
lesquelles vous sortez un peu partout il
y en a il y en a partout heureusement
plus en plus jolie même je pense à vous
semblez regretter qu'elles soient de
plus en plus jolie
non pas du tout non retrait je suis de
plus en plus content oui c'est vrai mais
c'est de plus en plus difficile parce
que vous en voyez vous sortez qu'une
fille qui est très bien puis dix mètres
plus loin et n'ont qu'une encore une qui
est encore plus bien alors comment vous
y prenez pour faire la paix mais sans
manger rire en chef ont un chèque de
certaines sont son truc
oui justement par les mâles vote truqué
vrai ben je sais pas moi j'ai j'essaye
de les distraire quoi je leur raconte
des blagues d'abord faut d'abord que
j'arrive à lacoste et syrie par trop les
choses m'ont essentielle pour trouver
sur moi pas pondre
pourquoi si ça marche j'essaye de la
distraire
je suis raconte d'un ton truc quoi
jeu-là bluff le plus possible je prends
ou la pétrir oui j'essaye beaucoup et
goethe importants provoqués le riz oui
nous sommes que quand elle rit elle
commence à marcher ouest sait pas
qu'elle commence à marcher mais c'est
que marque des points quoi et alors
après il fallait vous avez marqué ses
premiers points il souffrait pas
j'essaye d'en marquer d'autres c'est
d'en marquer d'autres en poussant sa
plus loin quoi je la raccompagne si si
besoin est cher frère je l'invite à
sortir du monde un tas de trucs quoi et
je lui demande s'il peut la revoir tout
ça quoi
et quand vous sortez avec elle c'est
vous qui payez au cl ça dépend un peu sa
fortune du pot quoi ça dépend comme un
d'argent je dispose c'est ici beaucoup
d'argent c'est moi je vais pas
difficulté mais quand j'en ai plus bas
si vraiment j'ai confiance en la fille
lui demande couac aurait mangé le monde
ça ne gêne pas de lui demander si ça me
gêne un peu quoi parce que c'est
toujours gênant de demander une fille
coin c'est vrai pour un peu con lem coin
mais qu'est ce que c'est pour vous aimez
évier
pour le moment c'est c'est pas grand
chose quoi pour moi je vois aimé qu'elle
me plaisent quoi pour le moment pour
sortir avec quelques occasions à tout au
moins à raison nous oui exactement et
toi vous passez de marier un jour oui
j'y pense oui
dans combien de temps à peu près trois
ans - agen on va vrai qu'on sera un peu
moins - gamin quoi je pense trois musées
alors une en trois ans dans 20 ans oui
oui ou d'avoir des enfants
oui je m'en avoir oui pour une tripotée
montfort
2 - vous pouvez me faire le portrait
d'attentes que
les 12 et j'ai moins qu'elle soit belle
évidemment mais j'ai moi aussi ce
qu'elle soit plutôt intelligente que oui
pourquoi parce qu'ils ne sont que c'est
mieux c'est plus agréable de voir une
femme même un peu moins belle mais
intelligent de quoi il me semble que
c'est d'ailleurs plus de rêve de côtoyer
des gens qui sont plus intelligents quoi
mes mains intelligent tout simplement
[Musique]